if you ended up with like a Nome they
would have policies that would really
accelerate the decline of this country
whereas I think Florida represents a
model where we can reverse the decline
and have an American Revival you don't
like him I know no I just don't like
well I don't like people that demonize
other people or or or uh or go after
vulnerable communities but also don't
like liars so that could be a preview
for tonight let's bring in Dave Rubin
host of the Rubin report and out kick
columnist Mary kathern ham I've been
looking forward to this for like two
months I am so excited that it's
happening because I'm looking forward to
some substantive debate on topics where
they'll be able to actually have time to
answer the questions Mary Katherine ham
what are you looking forward to tonight
yeah I'm also excited about this one
because these are two people who can
speak fluently about very different
Visions for America now I think one of
them is not a great vision and causes
people to leave the state of California
for the State of Florida which has
immigration in huge numbers and that is
something that uh undoubtedly Governor
Ronda sandz will be using against Nome
uh but even though I disagree with Nome
I like that both of these guys are
getting in the arena we have two Front
Runners in Biden and Trump right now uh
who are not making an argument to the
American people in an arena where their
ideas can be tested in large part I mean
Biden occasionally takes a question
Trump mostly does rallies these guys are
going to face off to tough questions
from each other and from the moderator
and I appreciate them going to voters
and making that argument and I'm excited
to hear it Dave you're like the a
oneperson focus group for for this we've
gotten to know you over the years you
left California and moved to Florida and
Rhonda santz is somebody that you think
does a really great job so what are you
looking at
tonight well look the contrast between
these two guys is absolutely staggering
and this is exactly the fight America is
having and needs to have there is one
guy Ronda santis who will have truth and
facts and economics and reality and
policing and getting rid of wokeism and
all of those things on his side and then
there's another guy who I like to give
the devil his du and in this case I mean
it quite literally uh he's a slick
salesman and that's all he is everything
Gavin Nome touches turns to crap I might
recommend any well I can't recommend
anyone go to San Francisco but he once
was the mayor of San Francisco and we
all know what happened to that place C
has lost a million people in two years
and Florida not only is Florida getting
a huge bulk of those people who are
firsttime Republican voters like many of
the people in my two companies who moved
to Florida with me but Florida when
Ronda santis became Governor you know 4
and a half years ago or so had
400,000 more Democrats than Republicans
it's now 500,000 more Republicans than
Democrats that's a
900,000 person swing we are the freest
state in the nation everything that
America is about is happening here the
right way everyone knows that's not
what's happening in Cali and I hope D
santis brings it and shows people what's
what and I think Sean is a great
interviewer and so this it's going to be
wonderful I'll be sitting there right
there with Percy by my side Peter to
probably also wanted to get to this
because it's really a lot very
interesting I know that both of you are
on X I am too and that would be formly
Twitter not the drug uh Elon Musk had a
take yesterday on with advertising well
I just realized it was like being on the
five I'm like wait did I just say that I
think we're not on X okay obviously um
but do tweet a lot and Elon Musk had
this to say to advertisers
yesterday if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go yourself go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob you're in the
audience well well let me ask you
then that's how I feel don't
advertise all right so he's saying don't
advertise then Mary Katherine ham what
happens to in the future well that's
what he's saying he's going to put it to
the people and say if everybody pulls
out and this company fails than it was
on the advertisers look I think your
mileage may vary on Elon Musk as the uh
as the owner of Twitter uh but look I
think he does unwise things I think he
says some unwise things I think he cops
to that in part of this interview where
he apologizes for things he's he's
tweeted and says like that was one of
the more foolish things I've done
however I do think there is Merit to
this idea of standing up and saying look
you can say sorry for certain things but
you don't have to lay down for every
single bully that comes to your doorstep
I think he's good at this I think Dana
White of the UFC is also good at this
and just and granted both of them have a
lot of resources in order to be good at
it but that's what they have at their
back and they can say to people
absolutely not I'm not going to bend at
every one of your requests and frankly I
think college administrators and college
presidents would be a lot better off if
they took just a little bit of that
energy to their own students who are
trying to bully them recently Dave ruin
I'll give you the final
word Dana Elon is almost single-handedly
saving free speech in this country we do
not trust big Tech we do not trust big
government but especially in light of
the events of the last two months since
October 7th there is one platform that
is allowing people to exchange ideas
freely sometimes that can be a little
ban in the butt when the Bots get in
there and the mean people are on there
uh but everyone that cares about Free
Speech the First Amendment at American
value should be standed by Elon Musk
right now great to have you both and
I'll be watching on X about what you
think about the debate I'm not on X
right now Dana I can tell I can you got
your wits about you indeed it's
ear hmer we are not sure really at this
point on that thanks
guys